grow a supercomputer in your garden
someday maybe transistors might already
be growing in your backyard for decades
they've been made from Silicon germanium
and gallium arsenide but it's a lot
easier to mine trees researchers at
Wallenberg Woods Science Center took the
lignin out of balsa wood then penetrated
the wood with a polymer to make its
fibers conductive and successfully made
the world's first wooden transistor this
is a step toward what researchers call
Electronic plants live or dead trees
that could contain on off switches for
applications like solar cells so team
trees may have planted over 20 million
trees but they also might have
accidentally planted 20 million
computers Vsauce one story down seven to
go this is mind blow we now have a
perfect 3D scan of the wrecked Titanic
we've seen glimpses of the Titanic and
video of its pieces and now we can see a
perfect 3D scan that is life-sized and
true to scale the Titanic is just under
900 feet long but it broke in half when
it sank its bow and Stern are now 2 600
feet apart and 12 500 feet below the
surface Magellan limited a deep sea
mapping company spent over 200 hours
using submersibles to take over 700 000
images of the wreck the compiled scan is
so detailed that you can see abandoned
shoes and unopened champagne bottles and
hopefully it will reveal the secrets of
the iceberg Collision that made it
famous it's been 113 years since the
Titanic went down and 38 years since the
wreck was discovered and despite being a
cultural and scientific Obsession we
don't actually really know that much
about what happened
sniff your pee like a Roman the form of
Caesar was completed over two thousand
years ago as an expansion of the Forum
Romano but 500 years ago a guild of
Bakers built a hospital there
archaeologists with the Caesar's Forum
project have Unearthed a cistern full of
medical waste from that era including
Matula glass flasks for analyzing a
patient's urine urine was a useful
diagnostic tool giving clues about a
patient's illness through color smell
and yes even taste by the 1700s pee
sniffing was a medical joke but urine
analysis continued to be useful for
diagnosing kidney diseases so I say
weenie weedy wee-wee teach a robot how
to be you Sanctuary AI has created its
sixth generation robot that starts by
learning about you and your life Phoenix
has a humanoid form controlled by
teleoperation where users transmit their
movements to the robot because Sanctuary
thinks the best way to build an
artificial mind is to start by
collecting data on what you actually do
with your body so instead of just
running a program to wash the dishes
it'll replicate how you scrape your
mom's charred meatloaf off a plate
Sanctuary has focused on hand and finger
movements Phoenix can't walk yet but it
can kinda dab electric brain sticker
electric brain sticker implants on the
brain require a hole in the skull that's
at least as big as the implant itself
but researchers at the federal
Polytechnic School of lausanne have
developed a sticker that works like a
ship in a bottle it's a soft robotic
electrocorticography grid that its
creators describe as being octopus-like
the Silicon rubber is covered in
flexible gold electrodes just 400
micrometers thick and it goes into a
hole just a fraction of its size and
then unfolds it's a minimally invasive
way to monitor neuro activity and the
researchers see it as being useful to
track implants for epilepsy but it's a
major step in brain computer interfaces
meaning I'm one step closer to getting a
PlayStation welded directly onto my
cerebral cortex hey are you a programmer
working on an open source project that
could disrupt the big Tech oligopolies
and uh here's another question do you
want to be paid to work exclusively on
your project well Futo the sponsor of
this video is now accepting applicants
for its summer Futo fellows program and
there will be another round for fall
just in case you miss summer I'm
actually friends with the guys from Futo
so I'm happy to spread the word for them
and help them find amazing candidates
who have open source projects and have
or plan to develop an honest business
model like one that doesn't sell users
data if accepted fellows will get up to
eighty thousand dollars per team and
housing and office space in Austin Texas
does that sound good to you yeah well
then click the link down in the
description below or in my pinned
comment to apply thanks to fudo for
supporting vsauce2 and uh good luck
programmers we found the world's oldest
blueprints precise architectural plans
depend on the careful application of
geometry trigonometry and art unless you
look like this Engravings from Jordan
and Saudi Arabia depict desert kites
which were massive structural funnels
used to trap animals what's remarkable
is that they're kilometers long so they
can only be seen from the sky that means
Stone Age Homo sapiens nine thousand
years ago conceived of something they
couldn't actually see and then built it
it shows incredibly sophisticated
spatial awareness and the successful
execution of abstract thought
bury your nose in virtual reality VR is
primarily Visual and tactile but
researchers at City University in Hong
Kong want immersive smelling olfaction
is a major part of a human's perceptual
experience and their mask can release
nine different scents and the wearer can
detect sense 1.5 seconds after
activation including mint Jasmine and
pineapple since were first injected into
theaters in 1868 and smellovision in
1960 revealed the problems with virtual
odors they're easy to pump in but
they're hard to remove to clear the way
for the next scent and you end up with a
horrible combination of some kind of
fart stink the chip and Bluetooth
technology in The Masks takes care of
that and researchers see the device not
only for entertainment but to be used to
replicate the smell of a loved one they
also made a five centimeter patch that
goes on the upper lip which can release
two different scents but maybe I don't
think I'll be wearing that in public
flinging pee with a butt catapult is
important I promise fluid dynamics are
an element of life and when your diet is
xylem fluid you're gonna expel a lot of
juice the glassy Wings Sharpshooter is
smaller than the tip of your pinky
finger but it has a mechanism that
achieves super propulsion a tiny droplet
of P forms and is immediately shot like
a catapult by its anal stylus which one
of its researchers calls a butt flicker
the amazing thing is the speed of the
droplets in the air is actually faster
than the movement of the stylus by a
factor of 1.4 the surface tension stores
energy and with perfect timing the
droplet Springs outward glassy Wing
Sharpshooters drink about 300 times
their body weight in xylem sap every day
so they get a lot of practice P flinging
and it actually is useful to us studying
insect deficiency could help us
understand how to shed water faster from
surfaces or removing solvents in
manufacturing nobody seems to want to
study me doing this and now the
surprisingly simple concept of the Sony
Walkman in 1983. take your cassette out
of its case and most people just see an
empty box but Sony saw something quite
different
[Music]
Sony introduces the only cassette player
as small as a cassette case the
incredible sounding super Walkman
[Music]